I'm Matt Papakipos.
I run the HTML 5
Open Web platform efforts
for Chrome at Google.
I'll be teaching a session
at Google I/O
about the Open Web platform
in Chrome.
This is the set of APIs
that Web developers can use
to implement applications
that do cool stuff.
Our aspiration is to make it
so that anything you can build
as a desktop application,
you can build
as a Web application, right?
We want Web apps
that are as cool and as capable
as anything you can build
on your computer.
So the sets of things
that we're working on
to make that happen
are video APIs,
2-D and 3-D graphics APIs,
native code execution
systems, um...
systems for doing
background JavaScript threads,
offline applications
that store on the local disk
and sync back to a server.
These are apps
that are starting to look
like traditional
native applications,
have all the same capabilities
and the same performance
and reliability characteristics,
but they run in your browser,
and they have all
the cool properties of Web apps.
You can use them
on whatever computer you're on.
You don't have to install them.
You have extra
security guarantees.
This is why we're trying
to bring the power of the Web
to the applications
you use every day.
In the session, we'll talk
about what the APIs are,
what the road map is
for when we're releasing
all of this in Chrome,
and where we're going
in the future.
Hope to see you there.